May mailman is a former Trump legal
adviser and she joins us now may uh your
take Republican
Governor has an opportunity to sign a
bill doesn't
why yeah he's my governor and I
testified on this bill alongside Riley
gains and a bunch of D transitioners
people who really care about this and
the ACLU one the ACLU congratulated Mike
dwine today and it's really perplexing
because this is a 70 30 issu 70% of
Americans say no to carving up kids
genitals say no to young men playing
women's sports and yet Mike dwine can't
agree with 70% of people why and you
nailed it there is money involved if you
look at nine of the top 10 Employers in
the state of Ohio they are related to
health care like Cleveland Clinic and
Abbot Labs which is the original
manufacturer of Lupron which is the
puber y blocker drugs they have a
headquarters in Columbus Ohio for their
nutrition Branch so this really boils
down to money I think there's also an
age factor I have to worry about my
daughters participating in sports with
boys and getting undressed in front of
boys Mike dwine is 76 he doesn't have to
worry about that he doesn't have to
worry about his kids getting carved up
as minors so you got to follow the money
which you're exactly right but it just
if it is a 30 did he get Hoodwinked does
he just have no courage is he afraid of
the backlash I mean okay the money thing
is legit I mean I that but what else I
mean ultimately you're the leader of a
state where you know your voters agree
with you on stopping something like this
and you cave
anyway yeah so I guess the option number
three is that he actually believes it
and that seems to be what the Ohio House
leader um one of the authors of the bill
seems to think which is is that he
actually thinks that if you don't cut
out a girl's uterus that she might be a
risk of dying but you know what the
studies say exactly the opposite people
who are transgender there was a study in
Europe have an eight times higher
suicide rate that means that the more
that transgender ideology pervades our
culture the sicker our people become the
sicker our kids become so how about when
someone comes in and they've got
depression and they got PTSD and they've
suffered from sexual abuse and they're
unloved and they're lonely and they're
confused about their gender we worry
about all those other things first we
treat all those other things first we
help people find religion we help them
find love we help them find community
and then we worry about the gender
transition later yeah and all in those
cases again it goes back to a system
that is incentivized to keep people to
be patients uh and Mike dwine is
furthering it May mman thank you very
much for your time hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else